Depending on what part, where you are at one part of the country,
or if it was a Trump rally and kill.
You think so? Yeah. We love Lieutenant Dan,
but I'll even call Lieutenant Wang. Okay.
Right. Lieutenant. Right.
It'd be a possibly safe version of that as you came out of wheelchair,
but you just put green screen on your legs.
So people know that you're not really.
No, no. Th the whole trick though, is to fool the audience, the artists,
the artists to push. These are just ideas that I have it, my little mind.
Sometimes they won't be executed.
You know, really does hurt me though. When people say that I'm dumb on Twitter,
people say that.
What is the one constant insult you've heard your entire life joking or dumb.
So that's why.
Yeah. Shaffir used to do it all the time that you're dumping,
never read a book and just tease me. And it's just like, sounds like trauma.
You think it is? Yeah, of course.
And it used to feed into something and I'm like, maybe I am dumb.
I don't think that I am.
I think that you have a different kind of intelligence
[inaudible].
That's.
True. Right?
Like traditional classroom intelligence is not a gauge for,
so like, it doesn't speak to so many other kinds of intelligence.
Well, like when I was in junior high, junior high, when I was in, uh,
a community college, junior high community college. Right. Yeah.
You get it. And, um, you know, I, I, the first, I only did a semester,
but the first semester,
the only good grades I got was in philosophy because I care for some reason I
was so depressed. Right.
That would just kind of dive into like philosophical ideas,
you know what I mean? And just existentialism or, or whatever, and whatnot.
And I used to like, you know, if I, if my interest is in something, right,
I'm full in it, you know what I mean? But if I'm not interested in something,
it just, just got, it kind of enters my brain and leaves, you know,
I don't have, like, I don't absorb things like star Trek,
next generation I'll absorb every information to it. Star Wars.
So every information.
How you can tell what he truly cares about or have interests.
Cause he has like a really good retention for certain details and like really
specific things like even people's names. But then, um,
for other things, absolutely like his,
his brain is wiped clean off of the information.
Like he doesn't retain any of it at all can.
Retain it. So.
It hurts me when I have to tell him like my life story for the eighth time.
Khalilah, you're different.
I feel like you almost retain a little bit of everything.
Yeah. That's it, that's like, I'm kind of an absorbent Tron where it's like,
I don't need to be actively listening for me to,
for it to be downloaded into my hard drive. Like somehow, like if it,
if I happen to see it, uh,
it it'll be tucked somewhere and I can retrieve it when I need to.
But, um, that's not a good thing.
It's not because you in life in order to be somebody who can, you know,
like have things roll off your shoulder,
you need to have the memory of a goldfish. Like I don't forget pains and aches.
Like things that hurt me, people have hurt me.
Like these things like are very fresh in my mind. Like I want to be like my,
my stepdad, Roger. I, he has like a seven, seven memory,
seven second memory. Like you could,
you could get into like a custom match with him and it's seven seconds later.
He'd be like, do you want some coffee, sweetie? Like he just has a bowl memory.
No, he doesn't. He's just always been that way. Like he doesn't have a very, um,
you know, he doesn't retain a lot.
Yeah. Like I'll memorize.
How many fish Jean-Luc Picard has in the tank behind him
crazy. Right. In an episode, I go, yeah, that's two in this episode. Right?
Like I'll memorize little things on people in the background of movies and TV
shows. Right. But then there's certain things that just like, I don't know,
especially like when it comes to science or something like that,
I just don't get it. Um, yeah. Or mathematics.
Mathematics. How far did you ever take math in college
Palomino? Would that.
I understand it. What I do,
the only way I can do it is like Stardew Valley. So this is how I count.
So what I'll do is, um, on my farm,
you get these pigs and the pigs, they, they, they release truffles.
Right. And sporadic, you don't know, you know what I mean?
So what I'll do is I won't count the truffles that they've.
Oh, this is good, Bobby.
I won't, I won't.
I won't count how many I pick up. Right. And I also won't comment,
count how many I have in the chest in one of my sheds. Right.
So what I'll do is I'll just pick them all up, pick up and then pick up all the,
all ones in the sh in the, in the, in the chest and then to put them in the, um,
the truffle maker machine. Right. I, so I've,
I've 30 truffle maker machines. It's a bit much.
You have to work to, to get these, to get the truffle maker machine.
We make them. And each one is very difficult to make, you got to get slime,
bright, classic. And it's either you have to farm them in, in, in, in, um,
mines, or you have to build it a slime farm, which I'm not going to do.
I don't have enough room on mine. farm for a slime.
Farm is the only space you have to take up for that.
I don't know too much about slime baby, but I trust.
Right.
And then here's the, here's the proponent that does very difficult to get.
Not just wood. You have to get hardwood. Okay.
And hardwood, you can only get that two ways,
three ways, hardwood. You can only get it from the secret farm for us.
That's the main way. Right. Which is far away. Yeah. They usually won't there.
It takes all day, no fast travel. D D uh, later in the game,
you can create these spheres or these podiums where you
can fast travel to places. You sound like an engineer to me, that's all. you.
All right.
This, this, this is slime naturally occur. Or are there like,
hagfish that prey in the water that produced this lime that you then harvest.
The slime is from the slime creatures, fish. Like hagfish. Yeah,
but they're in, um, they're little balls and they have a little faces.
Nolan hagfish look like they're fish, but they're like little eels. Yeah.
No, these are balls, baby. I don't like those. It's fine. It's the way the game.
Yeah. They're like little blobby balling. Right.
And they attack you've played it. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. You know about it then.
Right. So, um, they're cute. Right. But when they get angry,
sometimes they change color and they vibrate a little bit different.
And then there's salons with little, um, um, yellow tentacles.
They're rare and they're black. And if you kill one of those,
you'll get like shoes or like some sort of like, um,
a weapon.
Wow. That'd be nice if we could hunt. And then when you kill an animal,
it's not just the meat, but you get it.
Golden goose. Yeah. Yeah. The new slides, you know what I mean?
The spring edition that'd be nice or Montclair jacket. That's nice. Thanks.
Um, so how far did you get, did you get, ever get to the desert?
Um, yeah, I think that's, as far as I got the desert that's up North.
Yeah. Yeah. Thank you for exactly. So the desert has the best mine there. Right.
And it's, um, there's also these, um, all kinds of little creatures in there,
but, um, they're hard to make, so anyway, that's how I can count.
Hey guys,
we're going to take a really quick break to share some of our like favorite
sponsors with you.